Vince Vaughn was arrested early Sunday  morning ET can confirm according to  court records he was released on $5,000  bail and his next court date is  scheduled for September 10 a public  information officer with the Manhattan  Beach Police Department tells et that  the 48 year old actor was arrested for a  DUI Vaughn was reportedly stopped at a  DUI checkpoint at approximately 1:00  a.m. in California's Hermosa Beach  earlier this week the Manhattan Beach  Police Department posted this warning  about the checkpoint on their Facebook  page et has reached out to Vaughn's rep  for comments now this wouldn't be the  actors first run-in with the law in 2001  he was involved in a bar brawl in  Wilmington North Carolina  where he was filming domestic  disturbance with Steve Buscemi to do  Vaughn was arrested for assault though  the charges were later dropped